have you ever wondered about that tree
in lake hylia you know the one I'm
talking about that lone tree on that one
Island you got to take a bridge to it
you warp in right beside it cheek jumps
off the top of it like some sort of
danger or something you know that tree
okay good well does anyone remember the
huge freaking scratch in the side of the
tree that's only there in the original
Nintendo 64 version of the game no
you're not tripping it's real all right
now what kind of Claude monstrosity
could have scratched this magnificent
tree in such a way and why well let's
just say I think I have this figured out
hello my friends on the Internet
mask antenna bandit here and today I'm
gonna take you back to your childhood
back to our kareena of time as I
mentioned just a few seconds ago in the
video there seems to be a little detail
in Lake highly in ocarina of time that
nobody seems to be talking about over
the years I was reminded of it a few
days ago by a friend of mine and
honestly it's kind of surprising how few
theories there are on the subject I mean
that's not to say that there are no
theories on the subject some people say
that it's a wolf owes just you know
running around being a wolf those piling
up the moon
scratching trees stuff like that like
ten feet off the ground with claw marks
that are way too big to be a wolf
hostess vowel mark so some people say
it's the only owl that has ever been
known to talk more than he listens
capo Rock a bore scratching the tree to
market fur link or something like that
that really doesn't make any sense which
is why I don't agree with those theories
so without further ado allow me to take
you through my thought process also be
sure to like this video if you enjoy the
content and subscribe for much more
juicy sell two theories searching
Ocarina of times wiki page I found no
enemy that fit both the size and clawed
requirements to be our mystery monster
that would also make sense given the
lakes location I mean we have some
beasts that look like they could do
something like that like my boy dodongo
here or maybe my girl labeija but I
couldn't think of any reason why either
of them would be cruising out on the
lake you know being fired creatures and
all it began to become clear to me that
I wasn't gonna figure this out searching
information within ocarina of time
however you know how zelda games are all
held together by that bit of ever so
loved he had ever so hated thing we call
the time line well it just so happens to
link no puns intended the Zelda games
together meaning the lake hylia from
Twilight Princess or breath of the wild
for instance is most likely the same
lake we see in Ocarina of Time I took
this one step further though and
actually tried to fit Ocarina of times
lake hylia
into the one from breath of the wild and
wouldn't you know it it actually fits
now hang on let me explain an unknown
amount of time has passed between the
two games and a lot can happen like
terraforming the earth in that time but
there are some big similarities between
the two if we take our Mina's Lake
highly a map and overlay it on breadth
of the wilds at first glance it seems to
be completely different I mean the
bridges don't even line up I was lost
until I discovered this little
similarity in the top right of the lake
you see there's a waterfall sitting
right there and directly to the right of
it a path kinda sorta exactly like the
waterfall and path to the right of the
waterfall from a Karina's lake hylia so
with this in mind if we orient the
ocarina map like this and overlay it
this keeping in mind that bridges are
man-made and can be changed over time we
see another similarity and this is the
island that the tree was on it's in
roughly the same location as the island
with the shrine on it in breadth of the
wild we are now looking at the same lake
that must have given thousands of years
in between games changed and altered
over time but it's still roughly the
same lake and speaking the breadth of
the wild which takes place a long time
after all clean of time and merges the
timelines I began to ponder if there
were any giant clawed beasts that may
have originated in or around Lake heylia
and if you're any bit a fan of breath of
the wild I'm pretty sure you know where
I'm going with this there just so
happens to be a giant dragon complete
with claws of the sharpest caliber that
makes its home under the waters of Lake
High Liam meet Farish the lightning
dragon now I believe this already kind
of makes sense but where's the actual
proof I mean what more can I bring to
the table that would prove that Farish
is the perpetrator who scratched the
tree in ocarina of time and why would he
do such a thing you know I'm so glad you
asked that because I have three pieces
of really really good proof for this
theory first off if you take a picture
of Farish in breath of the wild his
description tells us a couple things
about our large flying zappy snake
friend most importantly we can read that
Farish is said to have served the spring
of courage since ancient times
now what the spring of courage is is
another theory in and of itself but what
I want to draw attention to is the fact
that this dragon is friggin ancient
ancient means really old like possibly
old enough to have existed all the way
back here in ocarina of time possibly
even older than this but that's not
important for this theory if Faraj is
that old or older that means he
definitely lived in or under the waters
of lake hylia in ocarina of time
emphasis on under the waters by the way
which is my second piece of evidence
which ties into my third piece of
evidence which is remember that beloved
temple in ocarina of time called the
water temple that's right there and lake
highly up well you remember these dragon
statues that are like all over the place
in the water temple you know the ones
that kind of sort of maybe look like the
head
a serpent like dragon in a game that
already features serpent like dragons
well allow me to suggest that Pharaoh is
the deity for which this entire temple
was built to worship and to house him
and he quite possibly still lives under
the waters of Lake heylia in his temple
to this day this day being breath the
wild I know right mind blown but but
wait you thought I forgot didn't you
even if Farish the ancient giant dragon
was old enough to be alive in ocarina of
time and was living under the waters of
lake hylia why did he scratch the tree
and how do we know that the temple is
still there in breath of the wild and
isn't he a little large to put such a
relatively small mark on the dead tree
well first off did you know that
reptiles never stop growing that's
pretty cool right but that's probably
one why Farish is so large in the first
place and to a means of explaining that
he was probably a lot smaller however
many thousands of years ago in ocarina
of time took place his claws could have
easily only been that big that long ago
secondly and well sadly we actually
don't get to explore under the water and
breath of the wild anywhere which is
pretty sad to me I suppose we'll never
know
fo sho if the water temple is still
there or not but thirdly and lastly here
is my theory as to why Faraj may have
clawed the tree in ocarina of time
remember when ganondorf's power was
released after link opened the door to
the triforce when he was trying to get
the Master Sword well remember how
Ganondorf wrecked havoc all throughout
Hyrule and released monstrosities in the
temples like maguro volvagia on the fire
temple and more feel in the water temple
I believe there was a big fight between
the dragon and the monster when more
feel infiltrated the waters of lake
hylia and the tree got damaged when the
battle happened I think they fought over
the temple more fuel obviously won and
was able to corrupt the temple so that
the water sage wouldn't arise until the
hero later on vanquished marshal from
the temple
I mean if you think about it more field
controls water and if that monster at
one point controlled all the water of
the entire lake before it was drained
man that must have been a battle of
truly epic proportions
so did I convince you because I'm
convinced I'm also convinced that you
should totally like this video and
subscribe to my channel for much more
content just like this in the future see
what I did there
drop me a comment below let me know if
you think I may have missed something or
maybe it was something else entirely or
just to say hi thank you guys so much
for being here and for watching and as
always you guys have a great rest of
your day peace out
[Music]